in general since the end of the Cold War
I think we've become a little bit timid
a little bit risk-averse in standing up
to some of the challenges around the
world and I think they're now coming
back to haunt us we've got uh
geopolitical shift in capability uh in
military might and agenda as well and I
think this is coming to manifest itself
in Ukraine I don't think Russia for
example would have invaded
um Ukraine had we not departed from
Afghanistan
and I don't think that China would be
doing what it's doing in the South under
sea and so forth if it didn't feel that
the West was so uh collectively divided
and unable to perhaps challenge
um these larger countries from perhaps
exploiting the limitations of our
International rules-based order